i didn't like to party i just like to
put myself in a crazy situation [ __ ]
yeah me too you know i was that's what i
was thinking about the whole time you're
saying that i go yeah i don't miss the
drugs
i miss the six o'clock in a diner or
waking up and some girl gives you an
audi to drive home
yeah you're like what the [ __ ] just
happened last night yeah dude i was in
louisville one time i came out of a show
they had a big group in a limousine they
invited me to go to after party with
them right
i was like i'm only coming if my boy can
come in like who's your boy
and i'm like le cedric they had a
brother nearby right wearing this louis
vuitton jacket dude
probably about 60 homeless right and
they're like that's your boy and i
didn't even talk to this dude
right i was like yeah that's my boy like
all right he can come
so i [ __ ] walk over him looking right
in the eyes and i was like
what's up man i'm theo he's like and uh
i was like all right dude i told these
people you're my friend you ever been in
a limousine he's like nah
i was like all right come get in with us
just act like you're my friend right
we're going to a party he's like all
right man so we go in the limo bro we're
in there hot chicks dudes people [ __ ]
cedric kept saying we're friends that's
what he kept saying out loud right
not the best actor bro what did we get
to this house party
it's a nice cool [ __ ] party bro i'm
downstairs i'm in the kitchen
somebody's making us a drink i'm talking
to somebody
[ __ ] is six minutes later right here
[ __ ]
somebody scream i hear a window break
right
somebody comes running down they said
some dude just stole like four purses
out of the coat room upstairs and
[ __ ] jumped out a window
that would have been me doug and that
was [ __ ] less cedric bro
and that was like but and everybody
there was like crying and pissed
and some girl was like furious because
all her tampons were in there or
something i remember
she got pissed she was a tough girl she
was like one of those uh
what are those people that slide the
thing on the ice she said curlers
she was a curler but i was
in my head i was like this is the best
[ __ ] night ever
just take a whiff for that fight you're
gonna take a whiff of your partner come
on
get a little air appetizer bruh treat
your nose
oh my god [ __ ] away